[Música]
con nuestra primera invitada al día
vamos a hablar de las relaciones de la
monarquía británica de la reina isabel
segunda esto con nuestra región de
américa latina y el caribe analizaremos
por supuesto la importancia de estas y
los pendientes también vamos a
profundizar en el conflicto de las
malvinas hablamos entonces con camila
perochena ella es historiadora de la
universidad
torcuato di tella esto en buenos aires
argentina gracias a mila por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
y empezamos dando un contexto no cuáles
han sido las relaciones más destacadas
de la reina isabel con los países de
nuestra región de américa latina y
caribe bueno la reina isabel viajó poco
américa latina' vino apenas tres veces y
en esos momentos los países que visitó
fueron básicamente méxico brasil y chile
esos son los países con los que guarda
relación porque tenemos que entender que
nuestros países no están dentro de la
commonwealth por ende nuestros países no
guardan una relación podríamos decir
cercana con la monarquía no tienen una
relación identificación con la monarquía
como tiene cualquiera de los países que
forman parte de la commonwealth donde si
bien la reina tiene un rol más bien
simbólico ceremonial como en algunos de
ellos como jefa estado en otros casos
como cabeza de la commonwealth son
países que tienen algún tipo de unión
con esa monarquía en el caso de américa
latina no es así no no y no es así y por
eso solamente vino en algunos momentos
como visitas ceremoniales pero no mucho
más que eso después con el caso
argentina no que
que lo mencionaba recién bueno en el
caso argentina las relaciones siempre
fueron distantes por por el tema de las
malvinas
entonces en ningún momento la reina
isabel vino a la argentina si vino el
príncipe y su marido el vino en una
ocasión vino durante el gobierno de
francia en la década del 60 pero no no
no mucho más que eso
claro que digamos antes de entrar en
tema a profundizar de las malvinas como
le estábamos hablando con la muerte de
la reina isabel segunda debilidad se
debilita la monarquía británica en este
momento digamos cuál sería también la
imagen del rey carlos o tercero y cómo
sería además esta relación para ellos a
calentar de los motores digamos con este
tema de las malvinas los británicos
también llaman las falklands bueno no
necesariamente se debilita la monarquía
hay que ver justamente lo importante de
la monarquía es que es una institución
que trasciende a la persona que las
ocupan o es en lo que la teoría política
medieval debería ser la monarquía es
decir la corona debería estar más allá
de las personas que ocupan esa corona y
eso hizo que la monarquía sobreviviera
durante más de diez siglos excepto un
breve inter reino excepto un breve
momento que es en el siglo 17 con la
república de chrome bueno durante todo
el resto de la historia en inglaterra
tuvo una monarquía y esa monarquía no
corrió en peligro de desaparecer en los
momentos en los que moría un rey y
asumía un otro de hecho por ahora sigue
teniendo una popularidad bastante alta
en inglaterra de más del 60% por lo cual
yo no creo que haya un peligro de que la
monarquía desaparezca sí creo que carlos
tercero tiene un desafío por delante que
es bueno cómo le va a dar su propia
impronta a esa monarquía es decir cómo
va a refuncionalizar la monarquía la
reina isabel hizo cambios en la
monarquía con la reina isabel la figura
de la reina o del rey se convirtió pasó
de ser la cabeza un imperio a la cabeza
de la commonwealth no hay hubo cambios
muy importantes en la monarquía y la
monarquía cloud sufrió y dio tuvo que
vivir y relacionarse a los contextos de
la independencia posterior a la segunda
guerra mundial y eso hizo que la reina
isabel le de su propia impronta a esa
monarquía bueno ahora el contexto es muy
distinto al contexto en el cual asume la
reina isabel la monarquía fue cambiando
a lo largo de las décadas y por ende
seguramente quedamos tercero le tenga
que dar su propia impronta
a esta monarquía eso es un desafío hay
que ver si logra conseguirlos los
niveles de popularidad
que ha tenido su madre pero yo creo que
eso no todavía no podemos decir que la
monarquía está en peligro de
desaparición ni nada que se le parezca
en inglaterra camila ahora sí entremos
en materia de las malvinas este
conflicto esta guerra de las malvinas
que finalmente ganó y ganaron los
británicos recordemos que pues fue
cuando estaba margaret thatcher al poder
cuando la primera ministra de reino
unido la reina se mantuvo siempre como
al margen de un pronunciamiento de
digamos directo no hablando de esta
guerra porque cuál habría sido digamos
el papel de la reina isabel según dan
las máquinas bueno la reina tiene que
mantenerse al margen de todos los
conflictos políticos internos e
internacionales porque ese es el rol que
tiene la reina no estar silencia sin
embargo hizo unas pocas declaraciones
sobre malvinas en esas pocas
declaraciones que hizo sobre a ella le
dio importancia y puso en un lugar
central a los isleños a los que viven en
las islas malvinas a los británicos que
viven allí y eso es muy importante
porque en los últimos 20 años excepto
durante el gobierno de macri pero más
que en los últimos 20 años lo que se
buscó fue sacar de la negociación a los
isleños es decir lo que buscó el
gobierno argentino fue en negociar
directamente con el reino unido porque
considera a los isleños a los que viven
en las islas malvinas como ocupantes del
territorio bien la única vez que la
reina isabel hizo referencia a las
malvinas pulso
dio importancia al rol de los isleños es
a esa guerra de malvinas que fue en 1982
pero que en realidad es un conflicto que
viene de hace muchos más años los
ingleses ocuparon malvinas en 1833
entonces ya en el siglo 19 los
diferentes gobiernos argentinos
empezaron a reclamar malvinas y ese
reclamo se hizo muy muy fuerte durante
el siglo 20 entonces cuando asume la
reina isabel ya había tensiones por
malvinas incluso antes de la guerra en
en ese sentido qué va a pasar bueno para
reiniciar él va a tener pocas relaciones
con argentina solamente 12 presidentes
van a reunirse solo con ella frondizi en
la década del 60 antes de la guerra y
después de la guerra del presidente que
se va a reunir con ella es carlos méndez
carlos menem fue presidenta argentina en
1989 mil 999 y esta reunión se explica
por lo que yo estaba diciéndoles antes
en relación con los isleños en la
política exterior de carlos menem estuvo
basada en un acercamiento hacia los
isleños entre argentina y los isleños se
reanudaron los vuelos a las malvinas se
empezaron a realizar por ejemplo
acercamientos otro tipo no hacer un
canciller salía en radio en las malvinas
y ese acercamiento que hubo entre
argentina y los isleños en la década del
90 hizo que carlos menen vaya a visitar
a la reina isabel
a fines de la década del 90 tuvo una una
reunión con ella incluso le regaló un
poncho y rompió el protocolo porque le
colocó el poncho y le puso el poncho en
sus hombros y eso fue todo muy polémico
pero la prensa él se lo tomó muy bien
ese podríamos decir que fue el único
momento de más acercamiento entre
argentina e inglaterra en relación a las
malvinas